[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentlemen, take your seats.
Our program is beginning now.
DAN BELCHER: All right.
Good morning, everyone.
My name's Dan Belcher.
I'm joined by my colleague
Vas Bala and David Hayes
from PagerDuty.
I hope you enjoy the keynote.
It's a good session.
All right.
At the keynote, we announced
Google Stackdriver.
And that's what this
session is all about.
It's about managing workloads
across cloud providers.
Since this was the
first day that we
announced Google Stackdriver, we
have a lot of ground to cover.
And so what we'll
do is first I'll
provide an overview of
the Stackdriver suite.
We'll do a demo with
a particular focus
on the monitoring and
logging components.
There will be a session
this afternoon focused
on the diagnostics components.
And that's Stackdriver
trace, Stackdriver debug,
and Stackdriver error reporting,
which we announced yesterday.
Then I'll hand it
off to David who
will talk about how Stackdriver
and PagerDuty work together.
And then finally, Vas will
talk about Stackdriver
in the broader context
of Google Cloud Platform
and how you can use tools like
BigQuery and Cloud Datalab
to extend the value of
your Stackdriver data.
So for context,
one of the things
that we believe at
Stackdriver is that visibility
shouldn't be so painful.
We started this journey
focused on monitoring in 2012.
And at the time, we met
with many, many customers
who were running applications
at scale in the cloud.
And broadly I could
say that they fell
into one of two categories.
The first category,
they'd say well,
we really don't
have the visibility
that we needed to
our application.
We're relying on some basic
capabilities from the Cloud
Platform, but frequently we're
surprised by performance issues
or outages or capacity issues.
So that was one
category of customer.
The second category
of customer would say,
actually then we're all set.
We have great visibility
into our systems.
We have actually
two teams that built
and maintain monitoring and
logging systems on our payroll.
And those are
teams actually that
are doing that
instead of helping
to build our applications.
And so one thing at
Google Stackdriver
is that visibility
shouldn't be so painful.
Another thing that we believe is
that we should be providing you
with insights to do your job,
not just lots and lots of data.
Because data actually
isn't that hard to come
by in monitoring and logging.
There are many ways that you
can get metrics, many ways
to get traces, logs, lots
of tools available for data
visualization, log analysis,
uptime monitoring, application
performance management, right?
There's a lot signals that you
can get related to performance.
In fact, alerting is
just another signal.
How many people have gotten
more than 10 alerts today
for an application?
100 today for an application?
A few, a few.
And when we talk about providing
insight, what we're really
thinking about is that silos of
data don't really help, right?
And this is one actually that
is important to us at Google.
And it's really difficult to
organize this type of data
and make it useful for people
who are operating applications
at scale if the data
is stuck in silos.
So part of Google Stackdriver
is about bringing that data
together so that we can
make it more useful.
Finally, this may be
a controversial thing
to say at the Google
Cloud Conference,
but, I'm going to say it.
This isn't about Google Cloud.
It's not about AWS.
In fact, I'm also
sort of in love
with metrics and logs and
alerts and that kind of thing.
But it's not about metrics.
It's not about logs.
It's not about alerts.
It's about you.
It's about the people who
are responsible for keeping
applications fast and
available and providing you
with the tools that you
need to do your job.
And the sort of general
theme that we're focused on
with Google Stackdriver is
making ops as easy as possible.
And our definition of easy is
can it be really easy for you
to find problems wherever
they're occurring
in your application stack?
Can we make it easy for
you to fix those problems,
get to root cause.
Can we help you answer
the very basic questions
that you need to
ask of your data,
like do I have enough capacity?
Are my users running
into errors when
they're using my application?
And can we do all that without
creating a really complicated
system that you
need to integrate
and manage and maintain?
And so that's what
Stackdriver is all about.
At a high level, as we announce
Google Stackdriver today,
there are five components.
Two, we did a brief demo
on stage in the keynote,
and we'll go deeper
into those two.
That's monitoring.
Think of that as alerts,
metrics, logs, and so forth.
Logging, which is
exactly as it sounds,
a really scalable
logging pipeline
that can accept system logs,
application logs, requests logs
and so forth and make those
searchable and available
to you.
And then three diagnostic tools.
One debug, so you
can debug issues
with your code in production.
Cloud trace, distributed tracing
for App Engine applications
so you can compare latency for
example between two releases.
And then error reporting,
a really exciting tool
that we announced just yesterday
that will automatically
detect when there are a lot of
one new type of error occurring
in your application and
notify you when that happens.
So this is the
Stackdriver suite.
We'll go deeper into
monitoring and logging here.
Just for context, the way that
we think about integrating,
so we think about
your application
stack-- so integrating at
the Cloud Platform layer,
integrating at the system layer,
integrating at the application
layer, and collecting
lots of signals,
whether that's logs or
metrics or traces or errors,
and then exposing
features that make
that data available to you.
So we'll jump into
the demo and show you
how this all comes together.
So this is the
Stackdriver home page.
You may have noticed
in the keynote,
we started with
a dark them, then
we jumped to a light theme.
That's one of the advantages
of the monitoring interface.
You can choose whether you use
a dark theme or a light theme.
I'll give you a quick tour
of the primary console.
Here in the top left
you see uptime checks.
So this is basically
probes that you
can configure to tell
Google servers to connect
to your internet
accessible endpoints
periodically and confirm that
they're up and available.
So this can connect over
HTTPS or HTTP or UDP.
Think of it as a
way of confirming
that your end users can access
your APIs and load balancers
and front ends and so forth.
Next below that, we
actually have a preview
of a new feature that's
related to our integration
with PagerDuty.
You can see that,
thank god, David is
on call right now in PagerDuty.
And if I wanted to
expand that, you
could see actually
who's on call next
and who's escalation
and so forth.
Below that you see sort
of at a glance help.
So this is where we try
to roll up these signals
into a very simple
way of knowing
whether there are any issues.
So here I see I have a
few App Engine modules .
And they're green.
We know there aren't any
alerts related to them.
I don't have to
worry about them.
Likewise there's a notion
of groups and applications.
So this is a really fundamental
concept in Stackdriver
where you describe how you think
about your cloud environment.
So you can define groups
based on, for example,
cloud accounts.
So if you have GCP
projects or AWS accounts,
you could group those
together in your Stackdriver
application.
If you have microservices,
you can define
groups for your microservices.
Now the important
thing with these groups
is you can define them
based on, for example,
naming conventions or tags.
And here I could choose
an AWS Auto Scaling group.
And I'd have a Stackdriver
group that corresponds to that.
So as new instances
are added to the group,
those instances are brought
together in Stackdriver.
And that becomes
really important
when you want to have dashboards
and alerting policies that
represent sort of
the architecture
of your application in
the way that you think.
And we'll explore that in
a little bit more detail
in a moment.
And then in the top right hand
corner of the Stackdriver, home
page you see incidents.
So this is where
you would see if you
have any alerting policies
that have triggered.
And we'll show you how to
configure alerts in a moment.
And then finally
on the home page
you have your sort
of, at a glance view
into the health of your
environment in terms
of key performance indicators.
So here the
application that I, I
have an Elastic Load
Balancer sending requests.
That's being routed
through an nGenx proxy.
And then traffic's
being balanced
across clusters on GCP and AWS.
And so these might
be the view that I
want, the metrics that I want
to be looking at every time
I open the application.
This is very configurable.
And then below I see
recent events or changes
to my application.
So this is where
you can see that I
have some alerts in
the demo environment
that triggered this morning.
Here is also where
I would see when
people make changes, bring new
instances online, and so forth.
So that's sort of the overview
of the Stackdriver home page.
Now I want to just give
you a little bit of context
in terms of how you get set up.
The first step in
setting up Stackdriver
would be to basically associate
your GCP projects and AWS
accounts to a
Stackdriver environment.
So here you see that I have six
or seven Google Cloud Platform
projects.
If I want to add a new project,
all I have to do is click Add.
I can select the
projects that I want
to add, and click Add Projects.
Connecting an AWS account
instead of being one step
is just two steps.
So the first thing
that you would do
is create a cross account
identity and access management
role inside of your
Amazon console that
grants Stackdriver access
to query the Amazon
APIs on your behalf.
And once that identity
and access management
role has been
created, then all you
do is paste the Amazon
resource name into this field
and click Submit, and
you'll be up and running.
Now when I say up and
running, what that means
is you'll have a bunch of
dashboards and visibility
by default. So you don't have
to go and set anything else up.
In about two minutes
you'll see, for example,
an inventory of
all your instances,
whether they're running on
Google or Amazon, in one list.
And this list could contain--
here I only have 116 instances.
It could be 1,016 or 10,016,
it doesn't really matter.
And I could easily search and
filter across those instances.
So if I want to look at my
Apache nodes, I can do that.
That's one default view.
Another one might
be if I'm using,
as I am in this case,
Apache web server.
So here, the Apache
web server metrics
are actually being collected
by our monitoring agent.
Our monitoring agent is
a package of collectd.
collectd is an open
source monitoring
daemon with a rich
community, broad deployment.
I bet many of you
are already using it.
And collectd also has
plugins to monitor things
like Apache, nGenx,
RabbitMQ, MongoDB, Elastic
Search, Cassandra, you
can go down the list.
And Stackdriver really
thinks that these
are sort of native services
that many of our customers
will want to use.
And so what we've done
is created dashboards
that automatically
show the relevant data
from those services once you've
deployed the monitoring agent.
And you can go deeper from here.
So I can look at, here
I have Apache metrics.
I could look at
host level metrics,
zoom in to a particular
time period, and so forth.
You'll see a similar
view on the cloud side.
So for example, when I
configure that AWS connection,
I could see my
Elastic Load Balancers
on preconfigured dashboards.
They're very rich
and designed to help
support the workflows that
you use when you have issues.
So for example, here these
are all of my Elastic Load
Balancers.
Here I want to look at one.
And when I drill to look at
that Elastic Load Balancer,
it's fronting a set of nodes.
And so I can quickly gather
key metrics for the ELB,
like latency, like requests,
like response codes,
and so forth.
But when I have an
issue, for example
that users are
getting errors, I may
want to try to isolate that
to an individual availability
zone.
So I can drill in and look at
latency, requests, response
codes by availability zone.
So here I can see, for example,
400 errors in us-west-2b.
And they're higher than
the others in the cluster.
Another case I could
actually go behind the load
balancer and look at
the individual posts.
So I can have a cluster
of hundreds of machines.
And this would give me a
way to drill in and look
at the capacity utilization of
the machines in the cluster.
So that's sort of
the native experience
that you would get with a
service like Elastic Load
Balancer.
And you'd see a
very similar model
whether you use on
AWS, whether you're
using ELB or RDS or
DynamoDB or Kinesis,
and you could go down
the list of integrations
that are available.
All right, I guess
it's about time that we
talk about Google Cloud.
So here you'll see, for example,
a dashboard for Pub/Sub.
In this environment
I'm using Pub/Sub.
And again, out of the box,
we get rich dashboards
for Pub/Sub, for App
Engine, for Cloud SQL.
You can go down the
list of GCP services
where I would have a
very similar experience.
And so this is sort of
how Stackdriver integrates
at that Cloud Platform
layer, at that system layer,
and some of these
application building blocks.
But these are all
preconfigured dashboards.
I don't know about
you, but I like
to create my own dashboards
and put them in the format
that I want.
And so here I can jump
in to look at a dashboard
that I've configured.
And it sort of brings
together these metrics,
whether they're on AWS
or GCP, whether they're
at the system level or the open
source sort of building blocks.
And here I might
want to actually look
at a view that shows a
little bit more data.
And maybe I want to
add more metrics.
And a couple really
important dimensions to this
are, we don't stop at
that open source layer.
We can go higher into
the application stack.
So you can send custom
metrics that you
define that might be the
starting point for looking
at the health of
your environment.
So in my case, I have a custom
editor for job completion time.
Now this is strictly
from my application.
There isn't an agent that
understands it natively.
And that's available
for me to chart,
to create alerts
on, and so forth.
And so I can add
it to my dashboard.
Finally, we can also get
visibility from our log data.
So we'll jump to the
logs in a moment.
But we can look at log metrics.
So these are metrics that I
define based on my log data.
So for example,
if I specifically
wanted to look at 404
errors in my Apache logs,
I could create a metric that
has those flow into the system
and bring that together
with the other data.
So here I'll save that metric.
And so one of the great things
that we talked about earlier
is how this data
all comes together.
And we try to make it as
insightful as possible.
Here I'll preview a
couple new features
that you'll have access to soon.
They're available on alpha.
The first is giving you insight
into kind of core statistics
across all of my charts.
So for example, if I go
to the three column view,
I can see at a glance what the
maximum and minimum values are
for a given time frame.
I can also expand this to
look at all of the legends
where I could, for example,
chart the standard deviation
across a large set
of data, or the mean
across a large set of data.
So if you're managing hundreds
or thousands of machines,
sometimes you don't
want to have a yarn
ball of lines on your chart.
You want to look at
your kind of key metrics
across these large clusters.
Secondly, in terms of
providing insights,
one of the things again
that we're working on
that I want to give
you a preview of
is the notion of vital signs.
So as I talked
about earlier where
we have all these
different ways of checking
to see if something's healthy,
what our customers have been
asking us for is kind
of a scorecard view
into the health of
their applications.
And so what vital
signs is all about
is when you describe
how you think
about your application using the
group concept that we discussed
before, we'll be able to
present a standard set of sort
of dimensions of health
of your application
and whether your
application is actually
healthy along those dimensions.
We're really excited
about this innovation
and look forward to
making it available soon.
So that's most of the sort of
monitoring side of the system.
But when we talked
earlier, we talked
about how we want to support
really rich workflows.
And sometimes it's not
just about the alerts
and the metrics.
When you find out at 3 o'clock
in the morning from an alert
that something goes
wrong, a lot of times
you want to dive into the logs.
And so one of the things
that we think about a lot
is how do we support that
troubleshooting workflow.
So you might get on
the alert and see
that you have a drop off
in your nGenx connections.
And you're kind of
zoomed into a view.
When you're looking
at those connections,
well, when we only have the
monitoring interface, what
people would do
is they'd say, how
do I double click on that
line and look at the logs?
And that's really what
we're building toward.
And so from here, with a
click, I can click view logs.
And this will dive you
straight into a filtered view
of the nGenx logs for
the specific resources
in the chart for that
specific period of time.
So you're not
wading through reams
of data trying to
correlate manually
across the different systems.
So we think this is really cool.
And as we mentioned
in the keynote,
it's really simple
to go the other way.
So I could search and
filter on the logs,
and then I could create a
metric that feeds the data back
into my dashboards, makes
it available for alerting,
and so forth.
One other point here, we've
talked a lot about alerting.
Let's make sure you
understand how alerting works.
So from this interface, I
could create a learning policy
by going to alerting.
We can also do it
from the charts.
So again, if you're looking
at that zoomed in interface
for a specific metric, you can
click Create Alerting Policy,
and it will take you directly
to that configuration
for that metric.
Here I'll do a little bit
more of a sophisticated alert.
So first you could
create basic alerts
where, I don't know if, I want
to look across my GCE instances
in my Apache cluster
on CGP and notify me
if any member of the
cluster has CPU utilization
above a certain level.
This is a very low utilization
cluster as you can see.
We could do that, right?
But the Stackdriver
system, because
of this notion of
alerts, you can
use it to have more
sophisticated alerts.
So for example on that cluster,
if you're running many VMs,
you don't really care often
about a single machine having
an issue.
I certainly don't.
What I care about is the
aggregate across the cluster.
So here for that GCP cluster,
what I might want to do
is alert on whether that
CPU again-- or let's
say Apache-- requests, the
total number of requests
in the cluster fall
below a certain level.
So here I could say it's a bad
thing if they fall below 160.
And then this alert would
go off pretty quickly.
So the alerting feature
set is very powerful.
You're able to sort of
express alerting policies
in a way that ideally
keep us from waking you up
at 3 o'clock in the morning
when there's not an issue,
but ensure that we do wake you
up at 3 o'clock in the morning
if there is an issue.
And there are many ways that
we can wake you up at 3 o'clock
in the morning.
The first one is email, right?
Of course I could
generate lots of email.
Many of you have just
told me, you probably
get a lot of emails on alerts.
We could do that too.
You could also use Stackdriver
to get SMS messages.
I suspect you get SMS
messages related to alerts
pretty frequently.
We can drop messages
into Campfire or HipChat
Or if you have a web hook, an
internal application that we
can POST JSON to
over a web hook,
the application can do that.
But perhaps one of our
most powerful integrations
and most widely
used integrations
is the one with PagerDuty.
And so to talk to
us more about that,
I'd like to welcome
David to the stage.
DAVID HAYES: All
right, thank you Dan.
Obviously PagerDuty
is super excited
to be partnering with
Google and Stackdriver.
But I'm especially
excited because I
get to show you a lot
of great new features
with our integration.
So our relationship
with Stackdriver
has extended back
for many years.
But today we're
unveiling a bucket
of great new functionality.
But first, what is PagerDuty?
What we solve is the
many to many problem--
relationship, sorry,
between your monitoring
tools and your people.
So you manage a
sophisticated infrastructure
and you monitor that with,
hopefully, Stackdriver.
It's a great tool.
But you may also be using
Splunk for log management.
You may sometimes find out
about things via tickets.
You may be migrating
off a legacy tool.
You may have some
custom tools that you've
implemented for
some edge cases that
are unique to your business.
And what we do is we roll
those up into services.
Because at the end of the day
or when something goes wrong,
you don't care what
tool got to it first.
You care what service is broken.
And then instead of mapping
those services directly
to people, we map
them to the teams.
So you were able to
manage your schedule
so you know who's on call
for a particular service.
Maybe I'm on call now.
You're on call next week.
We have a third person who's
on call the week after that.
And then we escalate
between those.
So if I don't pick
up my alert within,
let's say, 10
minutes, it's going
to escalate to
somebody else, and then
possibly to a third layer
to make sure that it's
resolved within the SLA.
And then finally the
bit that Dan alluded to,
we do wake you up at 3:00 AM.
Our goal in life is to
help you fix problems
as soon as possible,
but we are very noisy.
We'll phone you.
We'll push messages to you.
We'll SMS you.
We'll email you.
So what's exciting and
what's new as of today
is the Stackdriver-PagerDuty
integration
has three great new checkboxes.
It's bidirectional.
So whichever your
single source of truth
is, whatever screen
you're looking at,
whether it's Stackdriver
or whether it's PagerDuty,
you're going to see exactly
the same information.
So if your team
uses Stackdriver,
my team uses
PagerDuty, we're going
to be on the exact
same page as to what's
broken, what the state of the
world is, and who's on it.
We show the on call
schedules now in Stackdriver.
Again, so at a glance
you're able to see
who's responsible for fixing
anything should it happen.
And my favorite feature,
we now embed live charts
from Stackdriver in
your PagerDuty alerts.
So you'll be able to dive
in the second we notify you
and start resolving the issue.
Let's see some of
these things in action.
As Dan pointed out
earlier, we have
the schedule displayed
as a dashboard
widget in Stackdriver.
It basically just works.
And actually if you don't mind,
I'm going to go off script
and I'm going to thank your
design team, because that
is a beautiful looking widget.
It really captures
a concise view
of understanding
who's on call and when
that's going to change.
Stackdriver has a
concept of incidence,
and obviously
PagerDuty does as well.
And now the two
will stay in sync.
So we have here a
Stackdriver incident
referring to something broken.
And then in PagerDuty, we
have the same incident.
And as you can see, it links
right back to the Stackdriver
incident so that whatever your
next step's in resolution,
you're able to get there
quickly and effectively.
And like I said, my
favorite feature,
we show the live
Stackdriver chart.
So this is interactive.
I can zoom in to find out
exactly when and how something
went wrong.
You can tell just by looking at
this that I'm faking my demo,
that we basically took
a process and we killed
it and we were alerting on it.
But the big thing
you get from this
is as soon as you
get your alert,
you're able to tell
what kind of situation
you're dealing with
before you've even logged
in to any other
tools, before you've
jumped on to whatever
your resolution path is,
because the graph
tells you an awful lot.
So here's what we're going to
do the technically sophisticated
part of my presentation and I'm
going to gesticulate wildly,
because there's very
different kinds of graphs.
So if you've got a
threshold set here
and it's broken by
what we technically
refer to as a chugga,
chugga, chugga gradual thing,
you've got a very
different problem
than if you've got
a metric that's
chugging along at 1%
to 2% of the threshold,
and then shoots up dramatically.
Similarly, it's
up to the minute.
So let's say it takes those
10, those 15 minutes for you
to get woken up and focus
your eyes on your phone,
you're now looking
at this second's data
as opposed to when the
incident was triggered.
So you might even be looking at
the resolution or the incident
might have evolved.
So perhaps it's crested
above the threshold
and it's trending down,
which is a good sign.
Or perhaps it went
above the threshold
and it plummeted to zero,
which is a very bad sign
and you know you're going
to be dealing with a very
different kind of issue.
And naturally because we've
been working with Stackdriver
for so long, the
configuration is super easy.
You just drop in
your authentication,
or if you get to it before I
have a chance to change it,
you can drop in
my authentication.
And you've got a
perfect-- you've
got a smooth hand between
Stackdriver and PagerDuty.
And speaking of
smooth hand-offs, Dan?
DAN BELCHER: Thank
you very much David.
We've been really a great
partner with PagerDuty
now for several years.
It's one of our most important
integrations and widely used.
If you want to learn
more about PagerDuty,
they have a spot in
the partner zone.
So you could go there to
ask questions, learn more.
Integrations, there are many
in the Stackdriver service.
Some of the newest
and most exciting ones
are with our big data services.
And so what I'd
like to do is ask
Vas to demonstrate
how you can use
Google Stackdriver with the big
data services and Google Cloud.
VAS BALA: Thank you Dan.
We worked really
hard to make sure
that Stackdriver delivers an
awesome experience right out
of the box.
Hopefully you saw that in the
keynote and with Dan's demo
today.
And we're pretty confident
that for 90% of the use cases
our customers will
have, Stackdriver
is more than adequate.
But what about the
10% of the use cases
when Stackdriver isn't quite
the answer to your question?
You know today, other
vendors offer products
where it's either their
product or nothing.
We've taken a very
different position.
We think Stackdriver's
totally awesome.
But if you would like to get
directly at the underlying
data, we're going to give
you an ad hoc interface that
lets you play directly with
the data with Stackdriver
out of the way.
And I'm going to give you two
demonstrations that show you
how you can pull this off.
The first is an
integration with BigQuery.
As you heard in the keynote,
one of the things BigQuery
is really awesome for is dealing
with petabyte scale data,
with a simple SQL
like interface.
Now where do you see
petabyte scale data
where you need a SQL
like interface-- logs.
So I'm going to show you
in the first demonstration
how, with just a
mouse click or two,
you can stream logs from
Stackdriver to BigQuery
and go into the
BigQuery console,
and you have a query
playground at your fingertips.
Let's see that demo first.
So what I'm showing you
here is your logs view.
And you can see these
are actually logs
coming from our Amazon project.
So we are cross platform.
Now let's say that
the particular way
that we allow you to query logs
is not quite what you want.
You'll notice here
there's an Export button.
So when you click on
Exports, it takes you
to this view where you can
pick the service you want.
So I'm picking my
Amazon EC2 service.
And if you already have a
BigQuery instance set up,
you can select it over here, or
you can create a new one right
here from this menu, and
Stackdriver will take care
of all of the creation for you.
So there's no configuration
of BigQuery or any such thing.
Essentially two mouse
clicks, select, select,
you've got a BigQuery instance.
And now what happens
is really cool.
Stackdriver will now
automatically stream
your log data into BigQuery.
You don't need to
do anything else.
You can just go straight to
the BigQuery query editor.
And here I have
a query for which
I'm going to look at
my Apache access logs.
And if you're not familiar with
the BigQuery query interface,
it's pretty cool.
You can see your query, the
table schema details, preview.
And you can just edit your
custom query and just run
the query.
In this particular case,
I've picked a canned query
where I want to count the number
of HTTP 200 and 404 errors.
The Stackdriver
logs viewer is very
good at searching for
keywords in the logs,
but it's not set up to count
the number of HTTP 200 and 404
errors.
So just to show you an
example, I've taken this case.
And the query's
pretty long here.
And I'm also going
to group the results
by services and by region.
So let's run that query.
And here are the answers.
It's grouped by
region, shows you
how many 200 and
404 errors I get.
So here's a very
simple demonstration
of the power of running on
Stackdriver on the Google Cloud
Platform.
This is cross platform.
We took all the logs that are
already in Stackdriver driver
and we piped it into BigQuery
and gave you an ad hoc query
interface to play with.
All right, so onto the
second demonstration.
What about your time
series metric data?
That's another
valuable source of data
that Stackdriver
provides, I think,
a super cool awesome
interface for.
But maybe there
are situations when
you want to slice
and dice the data
and visualize it in
a way that is not
available in the
Stackdriver dashboard?
And perhaps you want to
run some third party tools
or open source tools on the
time series metric data.
How would you do that?
Well, welcome to Datalab.
It was briefly mentioned at the
keynote along with the BigQuery
presentation.
So let me just remind
you, Google Cloud Datalab
was a product we
announced last year.
It's in beta.
And it is based on Jupyter,
formally called IPython.
And it is baked into the
Google Cloud Platform.
So you could start up a Datalab
instance on any GCP project.
And it gives you an
interactive Python environment
to work with.
And you can just directly
program away in Python.
And as you saw in the
keynote, Datalab already
supports large data services on
GCP such as BigQuery, Cloud SQL
et cetera.
And what we're going
to show you now
is we've also added support
to tap into your time series
metric data inside Stackdriver.
And I think it's super cool.
Let's take a look at that.
So here we go.
What we're looking at here
is a Datalab instance.
And I'm pointing to this demo
project on which Dan showed
all of his graphs earlier.
And this is an IPython notebook.
So everything you see in
here consists of Python cells
that are all executable.
And when you execute
a Python cell,
its results are shown
immediately beneath it.
And it's completely
interactive as I'm going
to show you in just a second.
But the other really neat
thing about a notebook
is you can treat it like
a doc, like a document.
And this notebook can be
shared among other developers
within your team.
So it's awesome for running
what if experiments with data.
Hey, here's a query.
I ran a time series metric.
Look at what it found.
And just share it with
your other developers.
It's super awesome for
those kinds of tasks.
So let's first go
through a few canned
exampled I've got in here
just to explain how this works
and get a feel for it.
So what this shows
is at the very top
here I've got my import.
So from Stackdriver
import monitoring as GCM.
So this variable
GCM, that object GCM
contains all of the utilities
that we built into Datalab.
What's happening here
is I'm running a query.
This is just querying
the time series
metric data inside Stackdriver
for a metric called CPU
utilization over
the last two hours.
And I am restricting
the result set
to only be the data
for instances that
have a prefix called front end.
And in addition,
the dotted line says
I want to downsample the data
by five minutes using mean
as my aggregation function.
And the results go into this
Python object called q1.
Now in the Python
object, we've already
built in a few utilities
like line chart, right?
And this is just a fully
interactive line chart,
just like you saw
with Stackdriver.
We built yet another
utility called heatmap.
Again, the same data
rendered in a different way.
Sometimes heatmaps are really
useful in understanding
aggregate effects, especially
when your very large clusters,
line charts tend to
get very, very crowded.
But heatmaps are just
the perfect thing.
Discrepancies will
just pop out at you.
This is a tiny project so you're
not seeing as many instances
on the y-axis here.
But this is not about built in
utilities that Google provides,
it's about giving you
access to the raw data.
And this is where the
fun really begins.
With the same object
q1, you can get the data
as a pandas DataFrame.
Again, if you recall
from the keynote,
Google has built in
support for pandas.
pandas is a widely used open
source statistical analysis
package.
It's got a very rich
ecosystem of visualization
of other libraries
like scikit-learn
that you can do statistical
machine learning about data.
You can really
play with that data
in just a super cool
awesome way with pandas.
And what we show in here is
I just pull that data out
as a DataFrame.
This is a pandas object.
So this is a pandas utility that
says just show the first five
rows of the DataFrame.
And you can see the
data right there.
You've got the metric data.
First column are timestamps.
You can see there's a
hierarchy of column headers
that naturally tell you what
the levels of the hierarchy are.
You've got a project,
zone, group, et cetera.
And then you can do lots of
cool things in the DataFrame.
Now I don't have the time to get
into all the different things
you can do, but I
just want to give you
a flavor of the kind of data
that you can manipulate.
Over here I'm just
applying a filter
which takes a regular expression
on all the column headers.
And it just finds any column
that matches europe-west1-b.
And it's showing me
the data for that.
I can aggregate data
by project ID and zone
by just giving the
different levels,
by using mean as my
aggregation function,
and then doing a GROUP BY.
And I'm just showing the first
five rows of that DataFrame,
and so on and so forth.
So before I wind
up, when we were
doing the demo or
the keynote, right
in the middle of the demo,
Dan was standing over
in the corner, and
he toggled the load
so that the load shifted from
AWS resources to GCP resources.
And just out of curiosity,
I decided to hack this up
before I got here to see whether
we can actually see the Apache
request count metric
for the last two hours--
and I'm doing a downsampling
by five minutes--
if I can actually see that
load shift as a heat map.
So I have no idea what I'm going
to see, but let's check it out.
Oh, I just caught the
load shift right here.
I could have widened
the hours to three
and you would have seen this.
But what this is showing
is the top two instances
apparently were not involved
in the load toggling.
I think they were
backup instances.
But then you see
earlier in the time
there was a shift from
load from the AWS resources
to the GCP resources.
OK, so to recap,
what we're showing
you here is a way to directly
tap into the underlying
data in Stackdriver with an ad
hoc interface in the situation
where the super awesome
Stackdriver interface is not
adequate.
With that, let hand the
control back to Dan.
DAN BELCHER: Thank
you very much Vas.
All right, so to wrap
it up, first of all
we want to thank
you for your time.
It was a pleasure to tell
you about the new Google
Stackdriver.
We hit on a few key themes.
So the first thing
I'll recap is we
try to make it
really easy for you
to get the visibility
that you need,
whether it's at the Cloud
Platform layer, the system
layer, or the application layer.
Next we talked
about integrations,
be it the monitoring
integration with our agent,
our logging agent Fluentd,
or third party notification
tools like PagerDuty and Slack
and Campfire and HipChat,
and also these new and exciting
integrations with other tools
within the Google
Cloud Platform.
The BigQuery logging integration
was launched last year
to great applause.
Many of you are
using it actively.
The Datalab integration will be
available for you very shortly
and we're really excited about
that on the time series front.
We talked about insights.
Now what we think about
and sort of obsess
over is, how can we support
an operator or a developer
on call going from
that PagerDuty alert
or that SMS to go all
the way through whatever
signals they need to get
through to get to root cause.
And we show the
initial stages of that
in terms of integrating,
monitoring, and logging.
You could also see integration
between monitoring and tracing
and error reporting.
And so we intend to
go further and further
in terms of bringing these
tools and capabilities together.
And then finally we talked
about Cloud Platform
and how we embrace
Google Cloud, AWS.
And we intend to support
additional platforms as you
tell us that you want us to.
And so thank you very
much for your time.
You can try Google Stackdriver
free in beta right now.
And if you have any
questions, we'll
be at the infrastructure
and operations booth
out on the floor.
Thank you.